i have been babysitting for 20 years
i've seen it all
the thing is uh forrest is a unique
child everything is gonna be fine i want
you to have a good time tonight you
deserve it
okay um good luck
thank you
oh hey there forest
google i want
i want milk you want me to get your your
bottle buddy
i want milk okay
[Music]
this is a baba i want mama's milk
why can't i have mama's milk it's a
simple request
what yeah well uh you chick you can't
have mama's milk right now
buddy um how about we play okay
i want i want i want to play with my
legos
okay yeah okay buddy let's uh get your
legos done
i wanna i wanna put the smallest lego
in my mouth that's all i'm gonna do no
no you can't you can't do that
first you tell me i can't have mama's
milk now
became a smallest lego in my mouth what
a night this is a bad start
rapid force it's dangerous let me get
this straight
you're in charge of me in my house all
right
forest it's time for bed i guess then
you're gonna sing me a song
what mama always sing me a song before i
go to sleep
are you gonna do that for me okay okay
yeah yes i will
hush little baby don't say a word
keep keep singing mama's gonna buy
you a mockingbird put my name in there
i like i like it personal hush
baby forest whitaker don't say a word
mom's gonna buy you a mockingbird
good babysitter and if that mockingbird
don't sing have a good cry
my mama's gonna buy your time
[Music]